أظهرت الأبحاث بشكل كبير أن نمط الحياة المستقرة
يزيد من خطر إصابتك بالعديد من الأمراض المختلفة
[موسيقى]
لديك زيادة في خطر الإصابة بارتفاع
ضغط الدم وارتفاع نسبة الكوليسترول
والسمنة. داء السكري ، يعد
الحفاظ على القدرة على الحركة أمرًا مهمًا
لأننا
نحتاج إلى البقاء نشطين بدنيًا للبقاء
بصحة جيدة.
يمكن أن يمنحك التدريب الكثير من الفوائد الصحية
في فترة زمنية أقصر بشكل أساسي من التمرين
التقليدي للركض لمدة 30 دقيقة ، يمكنك
البدء
بدقيقتين للقيام بشيء ما
بقوة لمدة
60 ثانية تقريبًا وعندما تعمل على ذلك
يمكنك ربما فقط  قم بعمل 60 ثانية أخرى
من
بعض الشدة المنخفضة المعتدلة لجسمك
، ويعمل
قلبك باستمرار على إعادة تسريع نفسه مرة
أخرى
مع هذه الفترات القصيرة ، حيث يركض رجل واحد
من جانب متسلق الجبل
إلى جانب
الاندفاع ، فقط يقفز من جانب إلى
آخر
كما لو كنت تقفز  فوق الشمعدان ،
تأكد من أنك لا تزال تشعر
بالدفء والتبريد بعد كل جلسة صغيرة
دائمًا  استشر طبيبك قبل أن
تبدأ برنامج تدريب متقطع عالي الكثافة